Speaker 1: Welcome to the show,
hope everybody had a good weekend,
I will talk a little bit about mine on the bonus
show today. Some interesting things that went on
the vaccine. Chaos is growing dramatically and
we are already starting to see new talking points
develop from people who simply don't want to
talk about whether they are vaccinated. I will
preview that the term Hip-Hop plays a prominent
role in those talking points. We also have an
NFL assistant coach who is out after refusing a
covid vaccine. And the NFL clearly getting very,
very serious about vaccination. Rick Dennison
is out as the Minnesota Vikings assistant coach
after refusing a covid-19 vaccine after refusing
to receive a vaccine for covid-19. Rick Dennison
is out as the Minnesota Vikings assistant coach.
Sources told ESPN Dennison had served as the
Vikings offensive line coach run game coordinator
of the past two seasons. And a statement Friday,
the Vikings said they were still in discussions
with Dennison about the league's covid protocols.
Another coach in the league, New England New
England Patriots coach offensive line coach
Cole Popovich, also won't be with his team
in twenty twenty one. In a decision related
to the covid-19 vaccine and NFL guidelines. League
sources confirmed to ESPN the vaccine is required
for all Tier one staff, including coaches,
front office executives, equipment managers and
scouts. Players are not required to receive the
vaccine, but will face strict protocols during
training camp and throughout the season that
vaccinated players can forego. I will get to
that in a moment. In a memo released by the league
this summer, the NFL said any unvaccinated Tier
one staff member must provide a valid religious
or medical reason for not receiving the vaccine.
Losing Tier one status prohibits coaches from
being on the field and in meeting rooms and
having direct interactions with players. The
Vikings noted in their statement that Dennison
does not have a vaccination exemption. The Vikings
have promoted someone in order to fill that seat,
so on and so forth. So a few different things
to think about here. First and foremost,
is this guy Dennison going to eventually be a
Republican Congress candidate for Congress? Is
he going to appear on Fox News as a hero? But even
if he appears on Fox News, it would have to be via
Skype. Why? Well, even though Fox hosts talk a lot
about vaccine requirements and vaccine passports,
FOX requires that if you don't want to wear a mask
in their facilities, that you have to be wearing a
you have to be wearing a mask. So I guess this
guy could be hailed as a hero on Fox News,
but would have to do the interview via Skype
because he's not vaccinated. So that hypocrisy
is just incredible. Now, as I tweeted about
this, when the news broke, the team as a
private business made a decision about how they
wanted to employ people without breaking any law.
The coach made a decision about where he would
or would not like to work. This is, in effect,
the libertarian paradise. This is happening,
by the way, around the same time that the NFL
has had to postpone games because of coronavirus
outbreaks among unvaccinated players or staffers,
and that those are not going to be rescheduled, if
indeed that were to. I think I was not clear. They
announced that they will not be rescheduling games
that happen as a result of that are postponed as
a result of unvaccinated people. If people are
unvaccinated and there's an outbreak, that's
going to just be a forfeit. And the NFL getting
very, very strict about this stuff. They also
announced that they are going to be fining
unvaccinated players fourteen thousand dollars
if they violate covid protocols.
And the new protocols are quite,
quite interesting. The NFL having one list of
protocols if you're fully vaccinated and another
if you're not. So, for example, if you're fully
vaccinated, you don't need to be tested daily.
If you're not vaccinated, you will need to
be tested every single day. If you're fully
vaccinated, you don't need to wear a mask. When
you were at the team's facility or during travel,
if you choose not to be vaccinated, you will be
required to wear a mask all season, presumably at
club facilities and during travel. Other examples,
there will be no physical distancing required. If
you were with other vaccinated individuals and are
vaccinated yourself versus if you are not fully
vaccinated, you have to remain physically distant,
presumably for the entire season. So I don't know
about you, but if I was a player, I would
be wanting to be fully vaccinated in order
not to have to do any of that stuff. And
there are already people who are typically
on the oh, the NFL is so fantastic and it's
patriotic. And all of this stuff who are saying
screw football if they want to go woak, by the
way, following the science is not weakness. It's
just following the science. If they want to go
all whatever it is that the right. They are going
then I'm not going to watch the NFL is the
one that's coming up now, and you know what?
That is all the marketplace of ideas. The NFL
broke no laws by putting these rules in place
if they lose business or viewership or whatever.
As a result, that was their choice to make. If
people don't want to work for the NFL or for
any particular team because of the rules,
they are free to go and market their labor
elsewhere. And if the audience doesn't want
to watch the NFL in protest of these rules,
they are free to do that. And then that will
have an impact on the NFL, will have to decide
whether it's worth it or not. It seems to me,
based on everything that's going on, including
with the Delta variant, et cetera, that the
NFL is simply being cautious because they want to
preserve the integrity of their season and people
can disagree and then they can vote with their
eyeballs and choose to watch something else.